Law School is bull hey legal eagles D
James Stone here teaching you how to
think like a lawyer so you can crush law
school now law school isn't really bull
but there is one part of it that is a
total bait and switch that you might not
know if you're heading to law school for
the first time and you might not even
really realize that if you're halfway
through it and if there's one thing I
want you to remember about Law School
it's this only the final matters there's
so much crap in law school that makes no
difference for your final grades so
don't get bogged down in things that
just don't translate into grades at the
end of the semester and that's things
like case briefs cold calls in class and
sometimes study groups for most law
school classes the only thing that
affects your grade at the end of the
semester is your final exam for most
classes and sure there are some
exceptions to this rule the midterm
doesn't count class participation
doesn't count going to office hours what
the professor doesn't count doing killer
case briefs doesn't count it just
doesn't matter and the only thing that
does is your final exam at the end of
the semester and as a result that can
wreak havoc on what law students do law
students tend to be super a type
personalities who are used to having
waypoints throughout the semester tasks
that will result in a grade to know if
they're on track they'll have essays
they'll have book reports they'll have
midterms all of these things result in
getting grades along the way and it
seems like that linear progression
results in a good grade at the end of
the semester but in law school they flip
that on its head the only thing that
matters is the final so the most
important thing that you can do in law
school is focus on the things that help
on the final and those are things like
practice exams learning the strategies
for an issue spotting exam and by the
way you can get our checklist for final
exams in the links below there is so
much stuff during the semester that
seems incredibly important you know
reading every single case front to back
multiple
time's doing case briefs and law
students tend to be programmed into
thinking that this linear progression of
things is actually helping them to
achieve their end goal but in law school
that is simply not the case there is
just so much stuff that you can do and
everyone has the exact same amount of
time so the war is won and lost on being
able to focus on exactly the things that
actually do help if you're faced with a
task during law school the question you
should ask yourself is will this help me
on the final exam if it doesn't you
should consider replacing it with
something that will help on the final
exam those are things like practice
exams practice exams are one of the best
things you can possibly do to learn how
to ace an issue spotting exam at the end
of the semester it's things like
learning the strategies for writing an
issue spotting exam I bet that most
people go into law school without any
idea of the strategies that will
actually help them write a law specific
essay and here's a news flash
all of those essays that you wrote in
English class or for other classes in
college and undergrad those won't
translate into writing a law school
specific issue spotting exam so those
are just a handful of things that you
can do there's a quote that I love by
the Greek poet Archer locust that says
we don't rise the level of our
expectations we fall to the level of our
training and so many people go into law
school thinking what got them here will
get them there and that's just not the
case law school is a different animal
and it's too easy to get bogged down
with things that take up so much time
but have zero return on investment and
believe me I'm no different when I was a
1l and about halfway through my semester
I was preparing for being cold called
the next day the professor said that I
was the one that was going to be on the
hot seat and I was gonna be answering
the questions so I prepared like crazy I
read until 3 o'clock in the morning and
it occurred to me at about 3 o'clock in
the morning that all of this information
that I was studying this minut detailed
as my new chef was not going to help me
on the final exam I was terrified of
being called on in class by the
professor and looking like a fool in
front of my classmates but the truth is
I had read a couple of issue spotting
essays
and I knew that they just don't require
you to know that kind of detail they
require analysis and application and
learning that detail for class wasn't
going to help me learn how to analyze
things like an actual attorney so that's
when I learned that I needed to focus on
learning those skills instead of
focusing on the minutiae of things in
class and so I got through that day on
the hotseat and it was fine the
professor was a jerk and I didn't
especially enjoy it but I ignored it I
knew that that temporary stress was
going to give way to better grades on
the final exam because that was the
thing that I was going to focus on and
you can do the same thing it's a total
mindset shift you can make your life
easier and get better grades at the same
time by studying smarter and not harder
and focusing on the most important thing
to know about law school and that's only
the final matters so that is the one
thing that I would impart to new law
students out there if you want to know
more and if you like this video please
check out this playlist of videos that
are guaranteed to help you crush law
school so click on the playlist and I'll
see you in the next video